ah I got you good huh
Oh this Michelle my fish my Jack you
Shannon huh that's Michelle Nicole
Stevie's ex and just like the two park
movie she's gang-related
Michelle Nicole has the same problem as
many female gang members she can't seem
to meet the right guy and get about that
life
the guys that Michelle attracts and that
she's attracted to bring just more drama
in her life she's always what you did I
mean here but I heard of Dana so like
you feel me like I ain't except from
what I'm saying
I brought up said I'm just saying you
should date a different type of dude or
and or girl you know how you get in what
are some deal-breakers okay okay okay
but aren't you by yes I get it what's
the best date you had with a hard banged
out the best date I have was with me
we're breaking in cars that night no no
I already know because it was really
really breaking it cars are not like
babe you need to beat for your whips I
got hell yeah we could be icy ones only
got B right soccer game man
right I get in here I come on come on I
was like exciting the visa Stevie J
Michelle Nicole no way reflect the views
of James Davis Comedy Central its parent
company vitae let's face it
robbery dates just aren't healthy home
girl needs our help we're gonna set you
up on a speed date we're gonna get you
some other options come on down to don't
be aggressive in your dates just be you
I must and change Michelle Nicole but
I'm just saying don't scare them off
because you know how you don't have
nobody just relax my gosh I'm sure no
promise is going to be broken
time for Michelle Nicole to dive into a
whole new danger
no I'm Zach oh wow oh my coming in too
hot
I burn analyst I'm sorry loud and you
know I just get excited
Joey nice to meet you you sound a call I
love that name I also like those uh
burger DJ's you got on I got some white
ones I just got nice okay I waited okay
Jordan talk let me Dean well they're
Jays and not like one of the number ones
but Jordans on it what
oh you got to food to children I'm not a
really go I am a comic book dealer
we said no dealers but I guess we could
make an exception if a guy pitched my
ass would you fight him what kind of guy
are we talking about here
do me what kind of guy would doesn't
matter girl senator asked then
salah/prayer a will you not go stand up
for me and for me no I would you know
say something what the great hands doing
bro um so my nails uh I fell asleep at
the managers and my friends pranked me
they paid $20 for them to get painted
you cut your nails
oh wow those are nice did you you're
lying because I buy my skin nails now
you're a liar I'm not lying I would
never I wouldn't you just told me my
nails are nice and I know I have Kingdom
so you're a liar my dress code and we
can meet at the Ross clothes yeah
anytime
you know like for real get my number I
wasn't fabric it looked like then not so
diesel was closing the deal but you'll
never guess who Michelle Nicole chose
your low-key hothead she chose back
y'all so I hooked the vacuum was show
Nicole up with a his in her squad date
swag my first impression of Michelle
McCool was she's super intimidating but
like also like super attractive just
like so smart I've never met someone in
a gang or around a gang I think it's
cool that she's a part of them this is
definitely my first time dating the mom
I think it's cool that she's so
responsible and hey Michelle
Cole are you serious
michelle mccool got it she's not here in
jail